Wir wollen sprechen über Nationalismus und andere Tendenzen dieser Art bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Ein großes Thema, wir wollen es zumindest anreißen und die Frage beantworten. Hat das jetzt zugenommen oder ist das vielleicht auch selektive Wahrnehmung? Und was sind vor allem die Folgen daraus? Das werde ich jetzt hier besprechen, in diesem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch mit Ruben Gerczikow, Publizist und Autor und mit Inga Hofmann vom Tagesspiegel jetzt hier im Rasenfunk.
Was man sagen kann ist, dass hoch emotionale Momente bei großen internationalen Turnieren im Fußball, einem Sport, der ja nun wirklich die Gesellschaft durchdringt, dass diese Momente vielleicht wie Fotos sind von einer mehr oder weniger gelungenen Familienfeier, die man dann ins Album klebt und das ist ja auch schon was. Man kann sich dran erinnern und man macht das Album auf und sagt, guck mal, wie jung wir damals waren und es war ein glücklicher Moment und das war möglich. Also das ist so ziemlich das Maximum im Zusammenhalt, was der Fußball heute schaffen kann, aber das ist auch nicht nichts.
Derjenige, den ihr da gerade gehört habt, das war der Soziologe Albrecht Sonntag im Gespräch mit dem Deutschlandfunk und er spricht ja etwas an, was wir heute immer wieder indirekt streifen werden, nämlich Erinnerungskultur rund um den Fußball und eben auch die Tatsache, dass ja auch viel Positives mit dieser Erinnerungskultur zusammenhängen kann. Ruben, schön, dass du hier im Rasenfunk bist. Danke, dass du dir die Zeit nimmst. Was hängt denn in deinem Fußballfotoalbum an schönen Erinnerungen?
Danke für die Einladung. Ich glaube, die Frage lässt sich relativ einfach beantworten und zwar war es für mich das erste Europapokalspiel nach 25 Jahren des ersten FC Köln bei Arsenal London mit 20.000 Menschen durch London zu laufen. Diesen Verein, den man seit der Kindheit unterstützt, Dauerkarte auswärts, alles drum und dran und dann auch noch das 1-0 zu schießen, natürlich dann 3-1 zu verlieren, aber ich glaube, das ist ein Spiel, besser gesagt mehrere Tage, die ich so in der Art und Weise nicht mehr vergessen werde, vor allem weil ich das auch mit meinem Vater, der mich zum FC gebracht hat, erlebt habe oder erleben durfte. Und ich glaube, das ist auch etwas oder ist ein Fußballmoment für uns beide, der, wie es angesprochen wurde, den wir so nicht vergessen werden.
Aber gab es da auch negative Ereignisse? Das muss ja jetzt nicht immer eine nationalistische Parole sein. Es kann ja auch die Anreise zum Beispiel sein oder Verhalten von Sicherheitskräften zum Beispiel, wo du jetzt in deiner Erinnerung kramen müsstest, um dich auch daran noch zu erinnern?
Also ich sage mal so, die Einlasssituation aufgrund von 20.000 euphorisierten Personen, die, so sagt man zumindest, nicht alle unbedingt ein gültiges Ticket für dieses Spiel hatten, war etwas unorganisiert, um das mal so festzuzugehen, aber grundsätzlich verbinde ich abseits der Niederlage mit diesen Tagen in London eigentlich nur durchweg Positives.
Da sieht man ja schon, wie es funktioniert und das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, warum wir den Fußball so lieben. Inga, welche Fußballerinnerungen kleben in deinem Familienalbum?
In meinem Familienalbum gar nicht so viele. Ich bin nicht so sehr im Fußball sozialisiert worden. Wir waren viel beim Volleyball früher. Mein Bruder spielt selber Volleyball und ich war in den letzten Jahren viel beim Fußball der Frauen. Also hier Unionsfußballerinnen sind da gerade in die zweite Liga aufgestiegen. Da gab es echt ein paar viele spannende Spiele in der letzten Saison. Und nach Wolfsburg fahre ich auch manchmal ganz gern zu den Frauen. Genau, das ist also eher so in den letzten Jahren verstärkt dazugekommen.
Und wie denkst du über diesen Ansatz, den da Albrecht Sonntag vorgebracht hat, dass man trotz all der negativen Dinge, die eben auch bei diesem soziologischen Kollektiverlebnis Fußball passieren, über das wir gleich sprechen werden, dass man das auch nicht gering schätzen darf, dass ja auch die positiven Momente geschaffen werden? Siehst du da eher Gefahr drin oder würdest du dem zustimmen?
Ja, das ist natürlich immer ein ambivalentes Thema. Jetzt im Bezug auf den Fußball der Frauen zum Beispiel bei dem Thema, habe ich direkt gedacht, da trifft das in großen Teilen auf jeden Fall zu. Jetzt auch als die Union zum Beispiel aufgestiegen ist, da gab es ganz viele Familien, die zusammen da waren, die gejubelt haben, ganz viele junge Mädchen, die da ihre Fußballerinnen gesehen haben. Also ich glaube, es gibt durchaus Kontexte, wo das ganz zusammenschweißend sein kann, aber darüber werden wir ja auch gleich noch sprechen. Es hat natürlich auch seine Schattenseiten und man muss da gerade im Kontext von Länderspielen, im Kontext von Nationalturnieren auch sehr aufpassen und sich mal bewusst machen, was damit eben auch einhergeht.
Also wir werden jetzt heute quasi dann über den Moment vor und nach dem Familienfoto sprechen, wo man sich eben noch mit dem Onkel gestritten hat und wo es danach die große Eskalation gab, weil jemandem der Nachtisch nicht geschmeckt hat. Das sind heute die Themen, aber wir wollen eben nicht vergessen, dass es auch die andere Seite des Fußballs gibt, die ja vielleicht dann in so einem Gespräch dann mal unterrepräsentiert ist. Deswegen wollte ich diesen Einstieg wählen. Ruben, du beschäftigst dich mit diesen vielen der Vorfälle, die wir jetzt hier besprechen werden. Wir werden sie nicht einzeln durchgehen, sondern eher so grob im Gesamten das Versuchen einzuordnen. Du beschäftigst dich da schon länger mit. Hättest du gedacht vor der EM, dass es für dich so arbeitsreich wird in dieser Hinsicht?
Dass es diese Qualität und auch Quantität einnimmt, hätte ich tatsächlich nicht gedacht. Also ich war mir dessen bewusst, dass es zu Vorfällen dieser Art kommen wird, dass wir nationalistische Parolen oder Ähnliches sehen werden. Also dazu kenne ich den Fußball und auch die Vermischung zwischen Fußball und Politik einfach zu lang und zu gut, um das nicht zu wissen. Vor allem eben, dass wir mit Serbien, Kroatien und Albanien drei Länder aus dem Balkan dabei hatten, die ja eben auch eine kriegerische Vergangenheit bis Teilen auch Gegenwart pflegen. Von daher war das eigentlich relativ, zumindest in diesem Kontext, sehr vorhersehbar, würde ich sagen. Dass es sich in anderen oder bei anderen Ländern so entwickeln wird, wie es sich dann entwickelt hat, das war, glaube ich, nicht in der Art und Weise vorherzusehen. Nichtsdestotrotz, Inga hat es gesagt, Nationalturniere, Nationalmannschaften sind dafür auch gewisserweise prädestiniert dafür, dass es zu solchen Vorfällen kommt. Und auch wenn man sich vergangene Europa- oder Weltmeisterschaften anschaut, da würde ich vielleicht die Weltmeisterschaft in Katar ausklammern. Aber genau, es gehört gewissermaßen auch schon dazu, auch wenn ich der Meinung bin, dass wir uns nicht daran gewöhnen sollten.
Aber warum genau würdest du die WM in Katar ausklammern?
Ich würde darauf eingehen, dass zum Beispiel bei der WM in Katar, aufgrund der fragwürdigen Vergabe überhaupt der FIFA an Katar, als auch der Arbeitsbedingungen und der Sklaven oder der sklavenähnlichen Arbeit, bei den Baustellen, Todesopfer, Kathalersystemen, dass das alles auch ausschlaggebend Punkt gewesen sind. Warum zum Beispiel organisierte Fangruppen, die es ja durch auch bei anderen nationalen Mannschaften, jetzt nicht bei Deutschland gibt, die auch nationalistisches Gedankengut sehr häufig mit ins Stadion tragen, dass diese eben halt auch die WM, wie viele aktive Fußballfans weltweit, balkottiert haben. Ähnlich sieht es auch bei mir aus. Ich habe kein einziges Spiel der Weltmeisterschaft in Katar geschaut. Das heißt, selbst wenn es dort zu Vorfallen gekommen ist, habe ich die tatsächlich nicht im Blick gehabt. Ob es zu Vorfällen gekommen ist, kann ich natürlich abschließend nicht 100% sagen, weil ich mich mit dieser WM dann durchaus auch zu wenig beschäftigt habe. Aber grundsätzlich würde ich schon sagen, dass bei den meisten Weltmeisterschaften und Europameisterschaften es durchweg auch zu nationalistischen, aber auch zu rassistischen Vorfällen gekommen ist in der Vergangenheit.
Inga, du hast vorhin gesagt, bei solchen Turnieren, wo eben Nationen gegeneinander antreten, lohnt es sich besonders hinzusehen. Warum ist das so? Weil hier eben ein Länder-Wir gegen die konstruiert wird oder vielleicht auch, weil im Vereinsfußball es dann eher gegen andere Vereine geht und dann zwar sicherlich auch herabwürdigende und andere Parolengesänge, Zeichnungen und so weiter gezeigt werden, aber wir es eben hier nicht mit dem Begriff der Nation zu tun haben?
Ja, ich glaube, dass damit leider oft so eine Abwertung anderer Nationen einhergeht und man kann da ja auch wissenschaftliche Studien vorweisen. Die zeigen, dass schon 2006 im Rahmen der WM wurde ja danach, ich glaube, so etwas muss man auch unbedingt noch im Nachhinein im Auge behalten, sogenannte Fremdenfeindlichkeit zugenommen hat. Also es ließ sich statistisch nachweisen und auch andere Studien haben eben schon gezeigt, dass solche nationalistischen Ansichten zugenommen haben im Rahmen von Nationalturnieren und eben auch so Überzeugungen, wie Deutschland sei anderen Ländern überlegen, Deutschland müsse mehr Einfluss in der Welt haben. Also das lässt sich ganz klar nachweisen, dass das so ist. Und ich glaube, da kann man sich auch so ein bisschen fragen, inwiefern überhaupt solche Nationalturniere ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl oder ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl überhaupt stärken können oder inwiefern da eben auch eher so eine Spaltung mit von vornherein angelegt ist.
Ruben, du wolltest noch was ergänzen?
Genau, ich würde vielleicht da noch einen oder einen Punkt reinbringen, dass es eben halt auch bei internationalen Wettbewerben wie Champions League, Europa League und so weiter und so fort eben halt auch dann zu solchen Vorfällen kommen kann, eben wenn beispielsweise Vereine aus Ländern, die als rivalisierend gelten gegeneinander, spielen, dass es da durchaus auch zu solchen Vorfällen kommen kann, also dass es nicht rein auf die Nationalmannschaft zu beschränken sei, aber natürlich es stärker nochmal auftreten wird oder kann.
Stimmt, da haben wir natürlich auch schon genügend Beispiele gesehen, gerade in Qualifikationsrunden zu Europapokalen tritt das meiner Einschätzung nach häufiger auf. Da guckt man aber selbst auch glaube ich nicht ganz so genau hin. Jetzt ist die EM die größere Bühne und deswegen erklärt sich auch glaube ich, warum da mehr darüber diskutiert wird. Und jetzt hast du Inga ja schon diese Studien zitiert. Es gibt leider nicht besonders viele Studien, die eben die WM 2006 in dieser Hinsicht untersucht haben. Also wie eben der Patriotismus, der damals zugenommen hat, auch zu nationalistischen Tendenzen, zu rassistischen Tendenzen, zu Abgrenzungstendenzen geführt hat. Es gibt aber diese Studien, die das klar belegen. Kann aber auch beides vielleicht wahr sein? Kann man nicht auch sagen, also es hat das Wir-Gefühl gestärkt, also jetzt die WM 2006 und gleichzeitig hat es aber bei einigen auch den Rassismus und den Nationalismus gestärkt?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es gab ja jetzt bei der EM auch Beispiele, die das gezeigt haben, dass da auch gute Stimmung aufkommen kann. Ich denke da so an zum Beispiel die Schottischen Fans, die zwar haushoch verloren haben, aber da trotzdem irgendwie, zumindest in Berlin, da hab ich's beobachtet, für gute Stimmung danach gesorgt haben, irgendwie auf dem Dudelsack gespielt haben. Das waren auch sehr unterhaltsame Bilder, die zumindest so wie ich's wahrgenommen hab, nicht gewaltsam aufgeladen oder irgendwie problematisch waren, sondern die wirklich auf jeden Fall so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl gestärkt haben.
Da will ich auf jeden Fall nochmal, wenn du schon die Schottischen Fans erwähnst, hervorheben, dass sie vor allem auch in Köln sich sehr beliebt gemacht haben. Unter anderem auch aufgrund dessen, dass unsere Hymne oder die Melodie unserer Hymne ein altes schottisches Volkslied ist. Und dann gab es sehr, sehr schöne Bilder und Videos von FC-Fans und schottischen Fans, die dann zusammen unsere Hymne gesungen haben. Ich glaube, das ist zumindest ein kleines EM-Highlight bis jetzt für mich.
Okay, aber da muss ich jetzt wirklich Wasser in die Suppe schütten. Denn so sehr ich die Begeisterung für die schottischen Fans verstehe, muss man wirklich nicht genau hinhören, um zu hören. Also neben dem, dass da in diesem Fall dann Alkoholismus wieder total lustig ist und okay, während bei Fußballfans immer so getan wird, als ob das Horden wären, die durch die Städte ziehen. Also das ist das eine. Aber das andere ist, jeder zweite oder spätestens jeder dritte Fangesang ist abfällig über England. Und was alles schlimm ist an den Engländern. Warum ist denn das Ruben dann bei den Schotten offenbar okay? Und wenn das aber jetzt Albaner gegenüber Kroaten oder Serben, machen, finden wir es dann auf einmal nicht okay?
Na ja, ich glaube, dazu muss man auch sagen, dass ein ähnliches Spiel ist ja auch öfter, wenn Deutschland gegen Österreich spielt oder auch, wenn man sich früher auf Europameisterschaften anspielt, anschaut, die Niederlande gegen Deutschland. Also dass es da durchaus auch Rivalitäten gibt, die auf einer, ich nenne es mal humorvollen, ich will das nicht kleinreden. Und das sind natürlich auch an vielen Stellen auch historisch gewachsene Konflikte, die dort auch neu verhandelt werden. Wenn ich mir zum Beispiel die Erbfeindschaft Deutschland-Frankreich anschaue, die auch dann im Fußball immer weitergegangen ist. Ich glaube, das ist ein gravierender Unterschied. Und das ist da teilweise nicht, zumindest an vielen Stellen, ich will es nicht verallgemeinern, dass es da eben nicht in dieses Extrem nationalistische, sondern halt in einem Kontext einer Fußball-Rivalität gesehen wird, während das eben halt, wenn wir das Beispiel Balkan beibehalten wollen, dass wir da eben halt vor, bzw. seit den 90er Jahren, eben halt noch bewaffnete Kriege gegeneinander hatten, die auch für Fluchtbewegungen nach Deutschland gesorgt haben. Also es ist auch noch mal eine andere politische Situation als beispielsweise Schottland gegen England in dem Kontext. Aber natürlich, diese Sachen wurden natürlich nicht groß thematisiert. Ich glaube aber auch ehrlicherweise, dass sich englische Fußballfans weniger davon gestört haben, als beispielsweise serbische Fans während dem Spiel Kroatien gegen Albanien, wo eben dann Töte den Serben von beiden Fanlangen skandiert worden ist.
Aber könnte man da nicht auch sagen, ich nehme jetzt hier mal bewusst die Gegenposition ein. Ich verstehe schon, was du sagen willst. Aber ein bisschen hört sich das auch an, Inga. Du kannst auch gerne mal deine Meinung dazu sagen, als wäre es in Ordnung, wenn die Kriege zwischen den Ländern, ich sag mal 100 Jahre her sind, wenn die Kriege aber erst 30 Jahre her sind und wir alle Angst davor haben müssen, dass vielleicht neu ausbricht, dann ist es wieder nicht mehr, okay? Und gleichzeitig sind wir dann auf einmal der Maßstab. Eigentlich müsste man ja die Engländerinnen und Engländer fragen, wie denkt ihr darüber? Und wenn einem da dann gespiegelt wird, ja komm, wir sind ja genauso in die andere Richtung und das passt schon, das ist quasi wie, sorry, FC gegen Düsseldorf oder gegen Gladbach. Warum habe ich da Düsseldorf jetzt genannt? Da sieht man mal, wie weit ich gerade weg vom Bundesliga-Fußball bin, dass mir dieser Verfahren... Genau, stimmt, ich bin die überhaupt noch, habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Egal, das ist ein anderes Thema. Aber das zeigt ja schon quasi, da sind wir ja schon mitten im Geflecht der Schwierigkeit, solche Dinge zu bewerten und dass wir es Inga ja auch oft als Außenstehende bewerten und uns trotzdem eine Meinung anmaßen und man darf ja auch eine Meinung haben. Aber wie denkst du über dieses Geflecht an Problemen?
Na ja, woran ich gerade dieses Beispiel Schottland festgemacht hatte, war, dass es auf mich eine Stimmung danach war, die herzlich war, die ausgelassen war und die in keiner Weise angsteinflößend war. Ich glaube, das ist halt auch nochmal so ein zentraler Punkt. Ich habe von keinen englischen Fans berichtet bekommen, dass sie sich bedroht gefühlt haben, dass sie wirklich Ängste in dem Moment hatten, dass sie sich unwohl gefühlt haben und oftmals gerade nach eindeutigen Ergebnissen im Fußball ist es ja so, dass dann auch die Stimmung sich auflädt, dass es gerade für Frauen oder für junge Leute oder für queere Personen oder so einfach auch eine oftmals unangenehme Atmosphäre sein kann oder für die, die eben solche Gesänge dann oder anfeindende Gesänge entgegenbekommen. Und das war für mich eben so bemerkenswert, dass sie haushoch verloren haben und das ist trotzdem irgendwie, ich hatte das Gefühl, sie nehmen es mit Humor und deswegen hatte ich das hervorgehoben, weil ich das in keiner Weise irgendwie eine aufgeladene, beängstigende Atmosphäre fand.
Ich würde da vielleicht auch nochmal an einen Schlag an einen anknüpfen. Also eine gewisse Rivalität ist ja eigentlich auch Kern von Fußball und ich glaube, die Frage ist, wie lebt man diese Rivalität aus und wir haben ja öfter auch dann die Diskussionen, wenn wir uns über die Bundesliga reden, Schmähgesänge zwischen Dortmund und Schalke, zwischen Köln, Gladbach und so weiter und so fort. Das gehört gewisserweise dazu und ich glaube, das sagen auch immer die Verantwortlichen der Vereine, dass es auch gewisserweise dazu gehört, dass man mal vielleicht einen Spruch in die andere Richtung schickt. Die Frage ist dann, inwieweit können wir gehen und dann kommt natürlich die Grenze, wenn es zu körperlicher Gewalt in der Art und Weise kommt, wie es eben auch bei vielen Derbys in der Bundesliga in Deutschland regelmäßig der Fall ist und dann werden auch Unbeteiligte attackiert werden.
Der Unterschied zwischen Wort und Tat, aber da sind wir eben in einem Interpretationsbereich gelandet, weil den hast du ja im Vereinsfußball auch. Also der Hass, der gegen Rasenball Sport Leipzig geschürt wird, aus nachvollziehbaren Argumenten. Ich will nicht die Kritik an diesem Projekt wegbügeln, aber der hat sich durchaus auch schon an mancher Stelle und in manchem Fällenlager so hoch geschaukelt, würde ich sagen, dass man sich nicht sicher sein kann, ob wirklich da nicht hin und wieder auch Handgreiflichkeiten Minimum passieren gegenüber Fans dieses Vereins. Ohne dass ich sagen will, es wäre ein Automatismus. Aber da sind wir ja genau bei diesem Problem, dass wir eben jetzt auf Einzelfälle gucken in einem Gesamtbild, das aber eigentlich positiv ist, deshalb auch der Einstieg mit den Familienbildern und wir uns aber dann doch dazu verhalten müssen bzw. erstmal muss sich die UEFA dazu verhalten, die beteiligten Spieler, Trainer und Verbände und dann kommen jetzt wir, drei Schlauen und sagen, so hättet ihr es aber eigentlich machen müssen. Also bin ich gespannt, wo wir landen. Aber dann lasst mal reingehen in die Bewertung der Vorfälle, die wir jetzt bei dieser EM haben. Eine unvollständige Liste, also kein Anspruch auf Vollständigkeit und wir müssen die Einzelfälle auch nicht mehr diskutieren. Die Kroater und Albaner rufen gemeinsam, beim Spiel gegeneinander tötet den Serben. Melendaku skandiert Abfälliges gegenüber Mazedonien. Es gab eine Flagge von Großserbien zu sehen im Stadion, beim Spiel von Serbien, da ist eben der Kosovo einfach mit einverleibt gewesen. Es gibt Sprechchöre, soll es gegeben haben, von serbischen Fans, die einen Kriegsverbrecher gefeiert haben. Es gab Albaner, die eine Flagge einer paramilitärischen Gruppe mitgebracht haben ins Stadion, der eben zahlreiche Kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen werden. Es gibt ungarische Fans, oder gab ungarische Fans, die auf die Melodie von Lamour Toujour gesungen haben, die die Melodie gesungen haben. Das ist die Melodie, die durch das Silt-Video jetzt nochmal bekannter wurde. Sie haben auch Free Jiji-Plakate gezeigt. Das muss man als ein Code in diese Richtung verstehen, genauso wie auch österreichische Fans den rechtsextremen Code Defend Europe hochgehalten haben und auch sie das Lied Lamour Toujour gesungen haben und das auch noch mit der verbotenen Parole, die ja eben durch dieses Silt-Video jetzt weiter breiter diskutiert wurde. Wir haben das Symbol der grauen Wölfe gesehen bei Fans und dann unter anderem eben auch beim Spieler Mechig Demiral und wir haben deutsche Fans, die Hitlergrüße gezeigt haben, rechtsradikale Parolen skandiert haben am Rande von Fan-Zonen und so weiter. Ich persönlich habe auch im Stadion zum Beispiel das in Anführungszeichen berühmt berüchtigte Nationaltrikot mit der 44 gesehen, das eben der Zeit lang noch im Verkauf war, bei der die 4 sehr nach einem S aussieht. Das heißt, es sieht aus wie ein SS und diejenigen Personen, die ich da gesehen habe, allesamt Männer, die waren völlig integriert in die Fans, um sie außen herum. Also Inga, das ist jetzt ganz kurz mal eine Beispielliste von Vorfällen. Es sind noch nicht mal alle. Gibt es denn mehr Vorfälle dieser Art oder was wäre deine Anschätzung? Blicken wir vielleicht einfach genauer hin bei dieser EM?
Ich glaube, es ist eine Mischung aus beiden. Also viele europäische Länder erleben gerade einen Rechtsruck. Der macht natürlich auch nicht halt vor den Fußballfeldern. Das zeigt sich auch da. Rechte Gruppierungen nutzen eben auch solche Großturniere wie die EM, um da ja sich selbst zu inszenieren, um neue Mitglieder zu rekrutieren. Und gleichzeitig glaube ich schon, dass es zunehmend ein Bewusstsein gibt für diesen Zusammenhang von Sport und Politik, von Gesellschaftssport und Politik, der auch sicherlich in den letzten Jahren gewachsen ist. Da wir vorhin schon über die EM in Katar gesprochen haben, hat eine krasse Politisierung zugenommen oder zumindest ein Bewusstsein dafür, wie eng verwoben Politik, Gesellschaft und Sport sind. Und man muss glaube ich auch sagen, dass einfach bestimmte rechte Parolen auch salonfähiger geworden sind in den letzten Jahren. Und wenn wir so hören und lesen, an welchen Orten überall zum Beispiel der Hitlergruß während der EM gezeigt wurde, wie viele rechte Parolen geskandiert wurden, also dass dominiert ja jetzt nicht das öffentliche Bewusstsein jeden Tag ab, sondern wird mittlerweile schon so erwähnt, weil es eben so oft vorkommt, ne? Also ich glaube, es ist eine Mischung aus, das Bewusstsein ist gewachsen, es ist vielleicht auch salonfähiger geworden und diese politischen Entwicklungen, dieser Rechtsruck, die zeigen sich eben auch in den Stadien.
Ruben, du hast ja viele dieser Vorfälle auch dokumentiert, warst ja jetzt auch viel in Medien zu Gast. Würdest du da zustimmen, dass es eben tatsächlich mehr Vorfälle gibt und wir es deswegen auch wahrnehmen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es mehr Vorfälle gibt, um ehrlich zu sein. Inga hat es richtig gesagt, der Fokus liegt da drauf und was natürlich auch dazu kommt, Social Media. Wir haben eine ganz andere Art und Weise, auf diese EM zu blicken. Wir haben mit Livestreams, TikTok, Instagram und so weiter, haben wir Fans, die Fanmärsche selber streamen, die Fotos veröffentlichen. Das heißt, es braucht nicht mal nur Personen, die darauf achten, sondern man kann sich einfach Tausende Fotos, Videos und Bildmaterial anschauen von allen möglichen Spielen. Das hat es bei früheren Weltmeisterschaften, Europameisterschaften in der Art und Weise halt nicht gegeben. Das heißt, es ist viel einfacher geworden, auch Sachen zu erkennen, die vielleicht bewusst oder unbewusst gezeigt worden sind, ohne zu wissen, dass man eigentlich gerade fotografiert geworden ist, weil man sich eben halt auch so sicher gefühlt hat in diesem, ich nenne es mal Rudel an, das passt gerade im Kontext Grau-Wölfe, glaube ich, sehr, sehr gut, in dieser Menschenmasse. Da fühlt man sich natürlich auch bestärkt vielleicht auch ein wenig berauscht vom Alkohol, vielleicht von anderen Substanzen, in diesem nationalen Rausch dazu noch, dass man sich dann vielleicht auch dazu hinreißen lassen möchte, die Sachen, die man vielleicht in seinem normalen Leben nicht zeigen kann, weil man dann die Konsequenzen oder stärkere Konsequenzen spüren muss. Die Frage ist dann eher, warum schafft der Fußball diesen Ort, dass die möglichen Konsequenzen den Leuten im Kontext Fußball egal sind, sie aber im normalen Alltag diese Sachen beispielsweise nicht machen würden.
Na gut, es könnte die Macht der Masse sein. Elias Canetti hat ein ganzes Buch drüber geschrieben, inspiriert von den Gesängen, die er aus dem Fußballstadion gehört hat, bis in sein Arbeitszimmer hinein. Es könnte aber auch wieder unsere Wahrnehmung sein, Inga, oder? Wir wissen ja nicht, wie Menschen sich im Alltag verhalten und was auf irgendwelchen Grillfesten oder Gartenpartys passiert, will man vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen, geht uns ja vielleicht auch gar nichts an. Also es ist natürlich ein Unterschied, ob ich mich an einem öffentlichen Raum oder in einem privaten Raum bewege. Zwar nicht hinsichtlich der moralischen Bewertung, aber sicherlich hinsichtlich der Frage nach Sanktionen und juristischer Bewertung und so weiter und so fort, natürlich in einem gewissen Rahmen. Also, wie denkst du über das, was Ruben da gerade gesagt hat? Ich muss sagen, ich bin da noch so ein bisschen indifferent, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das bewerten würde.
Ja, ich bin noch so ein bisschen hängen geblieben bei Social Media und glaube auch, dass da wirklich eine ganz neue Sichtbarkeit für entstanden ist und ich glaube, es ist auch vielleicht an der Stelle noch mal wichtig hervorzuheben, dass dadurch auch vielleicht rechte Symbole, die vorher nicht so bekannt waren hier, also eben die über den Hitlergruß hinausgehen, auch gerade so, was andere Nationalitäten angeht, dass dafür auch ein Bewusstsein vielleicht geschärft wurde. Dass Aktivistinnen zum Beispiel über Social Media eine ganz andere Möglichkeit haben, darauf aufmerksam zu machen, davor zu warnen. Ruben hat ja auch vor ein paar Wochen diesen Thread geteilt und da eben eine Zusammenstellung von diesen ganzen Symboliken und ich glaube, dass vielen das auch gar nicht bewusst war, dass das alles damit reinzählt. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Social Media ein ganz zentraler Punkt ist.
Warum bist du indifferent, wenn ich die Frage zurückspielen darf?
Ja, sehr gerne. Ich glaube, dass es durchaus so ist, dass durch Social Media so Dinge schneller verbreiten. Ich glaube, ich springe damit so ein bisschen jetzt schon in unserem Gespräch nach vorne. Wir werden später das Ganze noch einordnen. Ich glaube allerdings, dass man an der ganzen Diskussion rund um diese Vorfälle auch ablesen kann, dass wir uns in Zeiten der Empörungskultur bewegen. Und damit will ich ausdrücklich nichts kleinreden und ich will auch nicht sagen, es sei nicht wichtig, darüber zu reden. Ich nehme aber die Art und Weise, wie darüber geredet wird, als relativ oberflächlich war und dann auch nicht so wirklich zielführend. Und im Grunde ist es so, also jetzt ganz salopp gesagt, und wie gesagt, ich will es nicht kleinreden, aber das ist meine Wahrnehmung, es wird ein grauer Wolf gezeigt und dann regen wir uns alle drüber auf oder viele regen sich drüber auf, die Gegenseite regt sich drüber auf, dass sich drüber aufgeregt wird und im nächsten Spiel wird, sei jetzt einfach mal eine Flagge verbrannt, dann regen wir uns darüber auf und die Gegenseite regt sich da drüber auf und aber eigentlich sind wir alle nicht so wirklich vorangekommen. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass Social Media da eine große Rolle spielt, aber wie dann die Diskussion jenseits von Social Media geführt wird, das könnte durchaus auch in einer anderen Bahn verlaufen. Ich habe aber das Gefühl, Social Media setzt sich im Diskurs dann eigentlich fort. Jetzt wollt ihr beide reingreifen.
Naja, sie darf halt glaube ich, also sie darf natürlich nicht auf Social Media verweilen, die Diskussion. Es muss halt darüber hinausgehen. Wir müssen auch darüber sprechen, wo braucht es Aufklärungsarbeit, wo braucht es Sensibilisierungsarbeit, wo müssen auch Gelder da reingesteckt werden, um solche Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten. Also natürlich darf die Empörung nicht auf Social Media verharren, sondern sie muss irgendwie diesen Raum verlassen. Aber um erst einmal solche Erlebnisse sichtbar zu machen, ist es, glaube ich, Social Media schon wichtig. Woran ich gerade noch so gedacht habe, als du von Empörungskultur gesprochen hast, interessant finde ich auch, welche Ereignisse da besonders groß auseinandergenommen werden, welche vielleicht weniger. Also ich persönlich hatte zum Beispiel den Eindruck, dass die Hitlergrüße, dass die rechten Parolen in dem Kontext fast ein bisschen untergegangen sind. Also sie kamen total oft vor und haben aber, fand ich, relativ wenig, über so meine Wahrnehmung relativ wenig Aufmerksamkeit bekommen im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel den grauen Wölfen. Und genau, ich glaube, man muss da allgemein auch aufpassen, nicht so mit zweierlei Maß zu messen. Ich weiß nicht, Ruben, wie siehst du das?
Ich finde das, was du gesagt hast, ist ein wichtiger Punkt, weil gerade im Kontext graue Wölfe finde ich interessant, wie die Diskussion verläuft. Zum einen, wie du gesagt hast, Hitlergrüße und ich nenne es mal der deutsche Rechtsextremismus, findet weniger Beachtung, aber alle haben eine Meinung zu dem vermeintlich, ich nenne es mal bewusst, in Anführungszeichen, ausländischen Extremismus. Und die bösen Türken, während man ja selber mit dem eigenen deutschen Rechtsextremismus nichts zu tun hat. Und da rede ich jetzt explizit nicht von den Leuten, die sowohl von dem Deutschen als auch vom türkischen Rechtsextremismus waren, auch wenn ich da sagen muss, Grauwölfe, Ükücü-Bewegung, das waren vor allem in den letzten Jahren eigentlich betroffenen Gruppen, die darüber aufgeklärt wurden. Das hat in vielen Stellen, wir hatten dann die Diskussion letztes Jahr um Mesut Özil und sein Tattoo, aber die wirkliche Aufklärungsbildungsarbeit haben kurdische, alevitische, asyrische, eisidische Menschen gemacht. Die deutsche Mehrheitsgesellschaft hat sich an vielen Stellen dafür überhaupt nicht interessiert und das, obwohl die Grauowölfe sehr aktiv sind in Deutschland. In den 80er Jahren ein Mord am Cottbuser Tor passiert ist, an Chilatien Käsien durch Grauowölfe unter anderem. Und da frage ich mich, warum braucht es erstmal diesen Torjubel von Demiral, damit wir überhaupt diese Debatte haben? Warum haben wir sie nicht nach Mesut Özil letztes Jahr geführt? Und warum wurde seit 2020, nachdem die Bundesregierung aufgefordert worden ist, ein Verbot gegen die Grauowölfe zu prüfen? Und da gibt es sehr, sehr viele Fragen, die da offen sind, die, glaube ich, müssen wir nicht alle heute klären. Dazu ist, glaube ich, die Zeit auch zu kurz. Aber es gibt mehrere Hürden, die man aber durchaus meiner Meinung nach beheben könnte. Also warum hat es vier Jahre quasi gedauert, bis wir eine erneute, stärkere Diskussion über die Grauowölfe in Deutschland haben? Das ist etwas, was ich mich, oder wo ich zumindest wieder Fragen habe nach dem Aktionismus und nach der vielleicht doch selektiven Aufmerksamkeit.
Und da würde ich eben die These vertreten, weil du gesagt hast, Inga, es ist wichtig, dass die Empörung nicht, also auf Social Media herausgehoben wird und dann in weiteren Diskurs führt. Ich nehme das wahr, ich sehe da aber nur graduelle Unterschiede in der Empörung, die dann in den Medien stattfinden. Für mich ist das weiter ein, wir zeigen, was wir doof finden und wir fordern irgendetwas. Meistens ist es, dass sich dann Menschen dieser kulturellen Gruppe zuschreiben, dass die sich davon distanzieren sollen. Das wird besonders gern gefordert. Wird komischerweise nie von Christen und Deutschen gefordert, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Da steckt auch noch ein rassistisches Denkmuster dahinter. Aber ich empfinde eben auch die weiterführende Diskussion als nicht fruchtbar. Und dann ist es tatsächlich ein... Ich bin immer sehr salopp, aber ich hoffe, dass die Hörerinnen und Hörern das eben auch richtig versteht. Aber es ist jeden Tag eine neue Sau, die durchs Dorf getrieben wird. Es ist immer wieder ein sich gegenseitig versichern, dass man selbst ja auf der richtigen Seite in Anführungszeiten steht. Aber letztlich passiert dann eben nichts. Weil wenn ich eben zum Beispiel höre, was Tubertecker zum Beispiel rund um die grauen Wölfe erzählt, dass da eben Betroffene davon berichten, dass sie seit Jahren Morddrohungen bekommen, ausgenau von Mitgliedern dieser Gruppierung oder von Mitgliedern dieser Gruppierung zumindest nahe stehen, dann wäre doch eigentlich die Aufgabe der Medien nicht zu sagen, guck mal, es gab jetzt diese Geste und das bedeutet sie, sondern wäre nicht eigentlich unsere Aufgabe, sage ich jetzt mal zu den beiden Medienmachenden bei uns hier, beiden Inga, wäre es nicht eigentlich unsere Aufgabe zu fragen, warum ist denn eigentlich solange nichts passiert?
Ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich kann da nur Ruben zustimmen, dass es total wichtig wäre, mal die Entscheidungen der UEFA überhaupt sichtbar zu machen. Und vielleicht auch mal sichtbar zu machen, was wird, also die UEFA verbietet ja politische Symbole, aber was wird eigentlich als politisches Symbol auch verstanden? Ich musste dann auch direkt gerade eben wieder an diese Regenbogen-Debatte zum Beispiel denken, was ja auch als politisches Symbol da von der UEFA bezeichnet wurde, wo man sich aber auch fragen kann, ist das ein politisches Symbol oder ist das nicht einfach ein Menschenrecht, ein universelles Menschenrecht und Transparenz, also Transparenz führt mir total bei dem Thema und irgendwie eine Nachvollziehbarmachung, wann, wo, wie reagiert wurde und vor allem, warum bestimmte und welche Symbole als politisch gelten, was als politisches Statement gilt. Ich glaube, bei der EM jetzt gerade ist ja auch wieder das Motto United in Football. Und wenn man sich so ein Motto auf die Fahne schreibt, was finde ich schon auch politisch anklingt oder zumindest einen Anspruch irgendwie erhebt, dann muss man diesem Anspruch auch gerecht werden und das gehört eben auch dann dazu.
Gleichzeitig haben wir da aber natürlich diese Dichotomie, dass die UEFA die Politik mit allen Mitteln raushalten will aus diesem Turnier, aus der Übertragung und auf der anderen Seite natürlich selbst höchstpolitisch ist, aber das ist jetzt nur eine nebenstragende Argumentation, aber auf der anderen Seite sich eben dann verhalten muss zu politischen Dingen. Und da sind wir ja insofern auch an einem kritischen Punkt, dass wir dann ja auch unsere vielleicht eigenen Wertevorstellungen, und damit rede ich jetzt nicht von Menschenrechten, die sollten universell gültig sein, da müssen wir nicht diskutieren, dass da auch Dinge sanktioniert gehören, aber dass wir vielleicht auch mit unserer eigenen Denke dann an politische Meinungsäußerungen herangehen. Also ich habe nämlich zum Beispiel noch eine Reihe von politischen Äußerungen rund um Spiele weggelassen, die möchte ich jetzt mal nennen. Es gab beim Spiel der Ukraine gegen Belgien, gab es Fans, die haben das Foto eines Mitglieds des Asow-Regiments hochgehalten und darunter war Peace has its price. Das sollte darauf hinweisen, auf die eben vielen gefallenen Soldaten. Dem Asow-Regiment werden aber zum Beispiel auch Kriegsverbrechen vorgeworfen. Sie haben dieses Banner zweimal hochgehalten. Beim zweiten Mal kamen dann Ordner und es wurde diskutiert. Danach war dieses Banner nicht mehr zu sehen. So wie ich es mitbekommen habe, gab es allerdings auch kein Einkassieren des Banners. Es gab aber zum Beispiel ein Bring him home Banner, das eben darauf hinweist, dass immer noch israelische Geiseln in Haft bei den Palästinensern sind. Dieses Banner ward verschwunden, nachdem Ordner vorbeigekommen sind. Das habe ich selbst im Stadion so gesehen. Und wir haben natürlich auch andere Positionierungen im Laufe dieses Turniers erlebt. Also zum Beispiel Michael Gregoritsch und Julian Nagelsmann halten Appelle ans Land. Julian Nagelsmann will aber vier Wochen vorher von einer Rassismusdebatte gar nichts wissen. Will dieses Thema dann raushauen, weil das könnte ja die Vorbereitung aufs Turnier stören. Der österreichische Verband distanziert sich zum Beispiel von Teilen seiner Fans, die eben dieses Defend-Europe-Banner hochhalten. Wir haben französische Spieler, die sich gegen rechts positionieren. Und wir alle wissen jetzt auch, wie die französischen Wahlen gelaufen sind. Muss man da jetzt nicht die sehr, sehr unangenehme Frage stellen, Ruben? Wie fänden wir das denn, wenn die sich für rechts positioniert hätten? Was natürlich jetzt ein... Aber... Also muss man dann nicht entweder ganz oder gar nicht sagen? Also entweder wir akzeptieren jegliche Äußerung und thematisieren aber immer dann, wenn es menschenrechtsverletzungen hinsichtlich roter Linien, die wir als Gesellschaft definieren, grenzüberschreitend war. Wie denkst du darüber?
Absolut. Ich glaube, der Fußball ist politisch. Inga hat das ganz am Anfang schon erwähnt. Der Fußball ist politisch. Der Fußball ist ein politischer Raum. Das heißt, er wird auch dementsprechend von Gruppen, Personen genutzt, die vielleicht eine andere politische Meinung haben als ich. Die Frage ist, wie reagieren wir darauf? Ich glaube, erst mal, jede Person darf im Rahmen der geltenden Gesetze. Alles andere ist, was wir als Gesellschaft sanktionieren wollen. Wir können ja nicht immer nur strafrechtlich Relevantes als ausschlaggebenden Punkt sehen. Das ist bei vielen Punkten unter der Strafbarkeitsgrenze. Das kenne ich vor allem im Bereich des Antisemitismus zuhauf. Von daher ist die Frage eher, wie reagieren dann Verbände, wie reagieren Vereine, wie reagieren vielleicht auch Mitspieler darauf, auf solche Sachen. Grundsätzlich hat jede Person, jeder Spieler auch das Recht, für seine politische Meinung einzustehen. Die Frage ist dann eher, wie wir als Gesellschaft damit umgehen. Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich die interessante Frage. Wie verhandeln wir politische Äußerungen beim Sport, beim Fußball? Ich glaube, das tun wir denn. Die Äußerungen, beispielsweise von Mbappé, haben jetzt nicht überall für Jubelorgane ausgelöst. Sie haben keine Jubelorgane bei vielen Leuten ausgelöst. Das heißt, da findet ja auch sowieso etwas statt, weil nicht alle Personen finden den Einsatz gegen die extremen Rechte gut. Das heißt, da findet trotzdem eine Diskussion darin statt. Ich finde es gut, dass der französische Verband das natürlich in der Art und Weise nicht unterbindet oder Sanktionen jeglicher Art gegen Mbappé. Ich glaube, das könnten sie sich auch, wenn wir diese Billwerke nicht leisten, das kommt auch noch dazu. Aber natürlich, der Fußball ist politisch und da ist eine politische Bühne. Das wird auch für extrem rechte Politik genutzt. Da muss man sich nur die ein oder anderen deutschen Stadien anschauen, wie wir damit umgehen. Das, glaube ich, müssten wir als Gesellschaft, als Fans, aber auch, weil du vorhin Medien erwähnt hast, als Medien verhandeln.
Aber findet diese Verhandlung denn eurer Einschätzung nach statt? Denn ich will diese Position, das ist jetzt nicht meine Position. Aber man kann ja sagen, müssten nicht eigentlich der ukrainische Verband auch dafür sanktioniert werden, dass die ukrainischen Fans eine politische Botschaft hochhalten, bei der eben auch, es geht hier auch um Landesgrenzen, also wenn eine Flagge von Großserbien aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen verboten ist, warum ist es dann in Ordnung, das Bild eines gefallenen Soldaten zu zeigen? Das haben die nicht so gemeint, aber der diesem Asof-Regiment angehört und das eben auch Kriegsverbrechen begangen hat, nach allem, was man weiß. Also machen wir es uns da vielleicht, Inga, nicht auch manchmal ein bisschen einfach, dass wir quasi immer das verdammen, was wir in unserer Bubble negativ finden und bei anderen Dingen dann eben dann doch nicht so genau hingucken, wie jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Wolfsgruß-Debatte, die ja riesig war?
Also ich habe diesen spezifischen Ukraine-Fall nicht mitbekommen, aber ich glaube, man muss…
Den hat man auch glaube ich nicht gesehen. Ich war da im Stadion, Entschuldigung.
Aber es ist natürlich, wie Ruben auch schon gerade gesagt hat, illusorisch aus dem Stadion so einen apolitischen Raum zu machen, weil politische Aktionen finden immer statt. Also egal, ob die verboten werden, egal ob die ignoriert werden, sie finden ja auf jeden Fall statt. Man wird, also die Politik kommt man ja nicht aus dem Stadion einfach raus. Und ich glaube, wenn man sich das vor Augen hält, dann sollte es eher darum gehen, wie gehen wir damit um, wie kann man irgendwie das in einen Kontext setzen, wie kann man dafür Bewusstsein schaffen, wie kann man darüber debattieren und das irgendwie dafür einen größeren Kontext schaffen. Ja und ich glaube, dass sich da aber auch schon in den letzten Jahren viel verändert hat. Also das Bewusstsein, darüber hatten wir ja am Anfang gesprochen, das Bewusstsein für den Zusammenhang von Politik, Gesellschaft und Sport ist ja total gestiegen. Und ich glaube, dass solche Debatten auch total helfen, da das Bewusstsein weiter zu schärfen und sich wegzubewegen von diesem Mantra, was irgendwie lange Zeit galt, Sport und Politik gehören nicht zusammen.
Ja und gleichzeitig haben wir aber natürlich die Problematik dann der Frage, wann wird sanktioniert. Weil bei juristischen Grenzeüberschreitungen ist es eindeutig, aber Ruben, du hast es ja schon angesprochen, ganz viel ist im vorjuristischen Raum. Das ist natürlich Quatsch, dieser Begriff, aber es ist eben nicht justiziabel und dennoch, aber entspricht es nicht den Werten, für die auch die UEFA eintreten möchte. Das heißt, sie hat eben auch Dinge sanktioniert, die eben nicht nach Recht und Gesetz, nach deutschem Recht und Gesetz verboten gewesen wäre. Also was wäre denn jetzt zum Beispiel gewesen, und danach lasse ich es aber auch mit diesem Beispiel, weil es tut mir selbst ein bisschen weh, aber was hätten wir denn zum Beispiel gemacht, wenn die ukrainischen Fans gefordert hätten, die Grenzen von jetzt, die sollten akzeptiert werden, wir wollen Frieden haben, damit hätte man ja auch quasi eine Grenzverschreibung vorgenommen, die wir jetzt bei all den Balkanstaaten, die wir vorhin bei den Beispielen, die wir genannt haben. Da geht es immer um Grenzen und um, was gehört jetzt noch zu welchem Land mit dazu. Also wie hätte man sich dann dazu verhalten sollen? Zeigt es nicht eigentlich schon das ganze Dilemma, dass jeder einzelne dieser Vorfälle einmal moralisch bewertet wird, einmal nach universellen Menschen richten und dann aber nach politischen Maßstäben und da unterscheiden sich die Lager, logischerweise, wen der Beteiligten man fragt?
Ich musste gerade irgendwie schmunzeln, weil als ich das gesagt hatte, das hatte ich irgendwie von meinem inneren Auge, dass das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht so eine Aktion während der EM gemacht hätte. Ich finde das Beispiel interessant, aber gleichzeitig auch extrem schwer zu beantworten, weil es gerade eben halt, oder weil, während wir gerade sprechen, es weiterhin, oder weiterhin der russische Angriffskrieg in der gesamten Ukraine stattfindet, gestern eben das Kinderkrankenhaus in Kiew bombardiert worden ist und ich glaube, es ist, was das angeht, eine andere Situation, als es auf dem Balkan in der Art und Weise ist und ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, und ich glaube, das ist auch das Problem, warum ich nicht adäquat auf deine Frage antworten kann, weil wir eben nicht wissen, was oder wie die UEFA diese Strafen verhängt. Und ich glaube, das macht das so schwer. Ich weiß nicht, ob es um die Verschiebung der Ländergrenzen in der Art und Weise geht. Beim Kosovo ist es ja nochmal ein Spezialfall, dass das Existenzrecht des Kosovo von serbischen Nationalisten negiert wird, also eben eines UEFA-Mitgliedsverbandes. Dass es dann nochmal eine andere Situation ist als eben dann im Kontext Ukraine und Russland. Deswegen diese Intransparenz gewisserweise bei der Verurteilung von politischen Botschaften, ich glaube, die macht das eigentlich so schwierig, auf diese Frage zu antworten.
Und ja auch Inga, weil damit ja auch gefordert wird, sich zu positionieren. Und in jeder Positionierung schwingt auch das Überhebliche mit zu wissen, wie man sich positioniert. Also was nicht akzeptabel ist und letztlich fordern wir das von der UEFA auch, ihr sollt euch positionieren und zwar transparent. Wir wollen wissen, warum welches Sanktot verhängt wurde. Auf der anderen Seite kann man ja aber auch genau das kritisieren, warum müssen wir als Medienschaffende uns zu jedem Konflikt positionieren, über den wir ja gar nicht Bescheid wissen können in all seiner Tiefe. Was man ja auch wieder rund um die Wolfsgruß-Debatte, da konntest du sehr genau unterscheiden zwischen Menschen, die sich schon frühest, spätestens mit Mesozozes Tastu damit befasst haben und eben jenen Menschen, die sich jetzt erst zu EM da kurz zu eingelesen haben. Ich finde, das konnte man relativ klar ablesen. Ist das nicht vielleicht so ein bisschen der Kern der Debatte, dass man mehr mit denjenigen sprechen müsste, die betroffen sind und deren Meinung dann aber auch anerkennen, selbst wenn es nicht die eigene ist?
Ja, also ja, ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig, das so gleichzusetzen von der UEFA zu erwarten, sich zu positionieren von einzelnen Menschen. Ich glaube, bei einzelnen Menschen ist es immer total hilfreich und letztendlich auch irgendwie total wichtig, sich dann einen Einblick zu verschaffen, wenn diese Konflikte verschiedene Perspektiven anzuhören, irgendwie eine Meinung zu bilden. Aber die UEFA als Ausrichter, als Veranstalter, die immer wieder diesen Slogan proklariert, keine politischen Handlungen im Stadion, die ist dann schon auch den Leuten, finde ich, eine Erklärung schuldig oder zumindest konkrete Regularien, konkrete Angaben, wie, womit umzugehen ist.
Ja, ich meinte auch jetzt quasi mit Menschen meinte ich uns Medien schaffende, dass wir dazu aufgefordert werden, uns zu positionieren. Hast du immer das Gefühl, dass du so dich positionieren musst? Ich habe schon den Eindruck. Also ich meine, da wird man natürlich auch oft Opfer von Whataboutism. Also wenn man etwas thematisiert, dann hat man auf jeden Fall 13 Kommentare, die sagen, ja, aber bei ABC, da hast du nichts gesagt. Und wenn man dann sagt, ja, da kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus, dann ja, das ist ja rassistisch, dass du dich jetzt nur mit den grauen Wölfen befasst. Und da endet dann eigentlich auch schon die Diskussion, weil da kommt man dann nicht mehr weiter mit Diskussionen. Ich habe diesen Eindruck schon, aber dein Punkt bleibt ja trotzdem genauso richtig. Die UEFA als Veranstalterin dieses Turniers hat eine andere Verantwortung und muss auch dieser Verantwortung gerecht werden. Aber Ruben, du hattest dich auch schon zu Wort gemeldet. Wo wolltest du einhaken?
Genau, ich wollte auf eine Sache eingehen. Wir leben in Deutschland in einer postmigrantischen Gesellschaft. Wir haben eine große türkische Diaspora. Wir haben eine Diaspora aus Balkan-Ländern, aus Ländern des ehemaligen Guslawiens. Beispielsweise, wenn wir auf diesen zwei Beispielen als, ich nenne es mal, ausländischen Nationalismus in Deutschland bezugenehmen wollen. Da gibt es ja auch genug Leute, die sich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzen. Also es ist ja nicht so, als ob es keine Journalistinnen gibt, oder türkischstämmige Journalistinnen, postjugoslawische Journalistinnen, die sich mit diesen Themen ja auch auskennen. Also es ist ja nicht so, als ob wir nicht auch Expertinnen, ich hasse diesen Begriff, aber ich nenne es mal Experten oder Personen mit einer gewissen Expertise zu diesem Thema, als ob es die nicht gibt und die gibt es. Und an vielen Stellen gibt es, kann man sie an einer Hand abzählen, was auch ein Problem ist, weil beispielsweise entsprechende Forschung nicht gefördert wurde. Ich hoffe, wenn man was Positives aus der Grauen-Wolfs-Diskussion nimmt, dass eventuell jetzt neue Forschungsstellen geschaffen werden, um sich auch noch mal mit der ÜLKiG-Bewegung in Deutschland dezidierter auseinanderzusetzen, dann finde ich, dann sollte man auch auf diese Stimmen oder vielleicht diese Stimmen auch ermutigen. Da denke ich beispielsweise auch an den jahreligen Journalisten vom Hessischen Rettungspunkt Daniel Majic, der extrem viel über beispielsweise Ustasa Nähe von kroatischen Gemeinden in Deutschland recherchiert hat. Das sind eben auch diejenigen, die mutmaßlich wahrscheinlich auch bei den Spielen der kroatischen Nationalmannschaften dabei gewesen sind, die ihre Sympathie eben zu Ustasa offen gezeigt haben. Und wir reden hier von einer faschistischen Organisation, des Nazi-Kollaborateurs Ante Pavlic, die eben auch für die Shoaf, für die industrielle Ermordung von Juden und Jüden, aber auch von Serbinnen, von Bosniakinnen, von Sintize und Romnias verantwortlich gewesen ist. Dann ist es auch, oder dann finde ich, dann liegt das auch, wenn wir über deutscher Erinnerungskultur sprechen und dass wir den Kampf gegen Rechtsextremismus ernst nehmen, dann heißt das für mich auch, sich mit Rechtsextremismus zu beschäftigen, der vielleicht nicht nur der Deutsche ist, sondern eben auch darüber hinaus. Weil schlussendlich bedroht dieser Rechtsextremismus eben Minoritäten. Wir haben es schon im Kontext der Grauen Wölfe gesagt, wir haben es jetzt gerade im Kontext der Ustaşar gesagt, weil das bedroht eben auch Menschen in diesem Land. Das betrifft auch türkische Oppositionelle beispielsweise, die vor den Grauen Wölfen nach Deutschland geflohen sind. Und wenn wir jetzt mit diesem Schutzversprechen auch ernst meinen wollen, dann heißt es auch, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Und das finde ich auch einen wichtigen Punkt, weil du auch darüber gesprochen hast, dass es natürlich auch rassistisch instrumentalisiert wird, aber dass wir deswegen keine Angst haben sollten, nicht darüber zu reden, weil das hat Birgit Rommelsbacher eigentlich ganz gut erklärt, dass nur weil man selbst von Diskriminierung betroffen ist, heißt das nicht, dass man nicht auch in der Lage ist, diskriminierendes Verhalten an den Tag zu legen. Und das trifft eben im Kontext der Grauen Wölfe absolut zu.
Und gleichzeitig ist zum Beispiel ein Bereich, in dem Diskriminierung immer noch weit verbreitet ist, seltsam unterbeleuchtet, zum Beispiel bei dieser EM. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass keine Queer- und Transfeindlichkeit passiert ist im Rahmen dieses Großereignisses. Und es zeigt ja auch schon, dass wir hier, warum lande ich heute immer bei Saloppen-Formulierung, aber ein Fass ohne Boden haben. Also das ist ja noch ein weiteres Thema und knüpft ja so ein bisschen an, Inga, bei dem, was wir vorhin gesagt haben. Welche Dinge bekommen welche Aufmerksamkeit und wie ergibt sich manchmal auch vom einen das andere?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich war jetzt ein paar Mal auf der Fan-Meile im Rahmen der Arbeit für den Tagesspiegel, auf der Berliner Fan-Meile und hab da mit Leuten von dem Safeguarding-Team zum Beispiel gesprochen. Es gibt zum allerersten Mal bei einer Europameisterschaft dieses Jahr auf der Berliner Fan-Meile ein Safeguarding-Team, was dafür zuständig ist, wenn Leute Diskriminierungen erleben, sexualisierte Gewalt, dass die dann als Ansprechperson fungieren. Und die haben mir durchaus erzählt, dass es immer wieder zu queerfeindlichen Beleidigungen gab. Der Berliner CSD, der ja bald stattfindet, da fand die Eröffnungsteremonie auf der Berliner Fan-Meile statt. Und da zum Beispiel kam es gehäuft zu homofeindlichen Kommentaren. Eine Dragqueen war zum Beispiel auch davon betroffen. Also diese Vorfälle gab es. Ich finde, dass, also in Berlin gibt es dieses Jahr auch ein Pride-Haus, ein Ort, wo gerade queere Personen und deren Freundinnen zusammen die Spiele verfolgen können. Das ist ein Poststadion, das ist auch eine sehr coole Atmosphäre. Dass es allein so was braucht, wo queere Menschen sich sicher führen können, wo sie gemeinsam die Spiele schauen können, zeigt ja schon, dass die Atmosphäre in den Stadionen auf den Fan-Meilen einfach nicht eine ist, in der sich alle sicher führen können, in der sich alle wohlführen können. Auf der Fan-Meile gab es zum Beispiel auch Fälle von sexualisierter Gewalt, übrigens verstärkt nach der Niederlage Deutschlands gegen Spanien. Also das sind so Themen, die auf jeden Fall auch total auf die Agenda gehören und wo es auch, glaube ich, total wichtig ist, noch mal hinzuschauen nach dieser EM. Also wenn diese Ergebnisse von der Safeguarding-Gruppe zum Beispiel ausgewertet wurden, sich dann auch noch mal anzuschauen, was kam dabei eigentlich raus. Weil wenn ich jetzt schon wieder höre, dass nach der Niederlage Deutschlands gegen Spanien es vermehrt zu sexualisierter Gewalt kam, dann zeigt das ja auch wieder, was halt diese aufgeladene Stimmung, dieser hohe Alkoholkonsum und diese eindeutigen Ergebnisse in der Kombination eben auslösen können oder verstärken können.
Ich fand es interessant, dass du während der EM davon gesprochen hast, weil ich finde, das Spannende ist ja eigentlich, es hat ja schon vor der EM stattgefunden, als es die Diskussion um das pinke Trikot gegeben hat und das ja durchaus in eine sehr queerfeindliche Richtung gegangen ist. Inzwischen ist das Trikot das am meisten verkaufteste Auswärtstrikot, wenn ich das richtig bin, weil ich die Zahlen nicht im Kopf habe, aber es ist ja zu einem Kassenschlager geworden. Und wenn ich mir die Debatte vor der EM anschaue, wie darüber gesprochen worden ist, dann würde ich sagen, ist das natürlich auch ein Indikator dafür, wie teilweise verwoben Queerfeindlichkeit auch im Fußball weitestgehend ist. Ich möchte jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jedes Kabinengespräch von den ein oder anderen Mannschaften mit anhören. Ich habe selber jahrelang Fußball gespielt. Ich glaube, das wird sich an vielen Stellen nicht unbedingt unterscheiden.
Vor der EM ging es auf jeden Fall schon los und es wird ja auch immer noch Leuten eine Bühne geboten, prominenten Leuten dann eine Bühne geboten, die solche Aussagen tätigen. Also jetzt zum Beispiel Jens Lehmann, der sich über die pinken Haare von Andrich lustig gemacht hat und meint, man wüsste ja nicht, ob er eine Frau oder ein Mann sei. Also es ist ja auch, da steckt ja auch was total Queerfeindliches dahinter und solche Menschen wird ja eben aber auch immer noch eine Bühne gegeben für deren Aussagen. Es ist ja nicht das erste Mal, dass Jens Lehmann mit so einer Aussage auffällt, also ja, da fehlt es auf jeden Fall noch an kritischem Bewusstsein.
Ja, und Innenblick und Außenblick unterscheiden sich da. Es gab im Deutschlandfunk, ich werde es verlinken, ein relativ kurzes Stück dazu, wie gerade vor allem in Katar und in der arabischen Welt generell über diese EM berichtet wird. Und da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, da werden natürlich ganz andere Themen hervorgehoben. Und ich glaube, da würden auch solche queerfeindlichen Übergriffe nochmal anders thematisiert werden, nämlich nach dem Sinne, guck mal, die wollten uns vorwerfen, bei uns war alles so schlimm, Regenbogenfahne und so weiter und in ihrem eigenen Land. Ohne, dass ich mir natürlich jetzt diese Meinung zu eigen machen will. Aber das zeigt ja auch schon, ich bin mir auch ganz sicher, dass wir haben das bei türkischen Medien und deutschen Medien beim Wolfsgruß mitbekommen, aber auch rund um die anderen Vorfälle, die jetzt eher Staaten des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens betreffen. Auch da wurde lokal ganz anders berichtet, naturgemäß, als eben hier berichtet wurde. Aber was wir ja eigentlich jetzt so ein bisschen herausgearbeitet haben, war, wir haben das Familienfoto, auf dem wir alle schön lächeln, da erinnern wir uns dran. Das ist dann für jeden eine andere Erinnerung, aber wahrscheinlich eine positive. Und dann sind es eben meinetwegen die betrunkenen Schotten, die die FC-Hymne spielen. Ich finde das ja auch gut. Und ich verstehe auch, warum sich FC-Fans und Schottland-Fans angesichts der sportlichen Ergebnisse gerade sehr eng miteinander verworben fühlen. Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber auch die Momente, die vor und nach diesem Familienfoto passiert sind, über die wir jetzt viel gesprochen haben. Und wir haben Aussagen, wie eben von Uli Hoeneß, der gesagt hat, dieses Turnier hat Europa zusammengeführt. Inga, wie denkst du darüber? Und daran hängt ja dann quasi der Aspekt. Kann auch eine Chance darin liegen, dass wir uns das schöne Familienfoto angucken, das uns groß einrahmen und aber auch hin und wieder darüber sprechen? Wisst ihr noch, wie davor der Onkel ausgerastet ist? Und wisst ihr noch danach, wie Streit ums Dessert gab?
Es gehört auf jeden Fall beides dazu. Ja, Julian Nagelsmann hat ja auch am Ende des Turniers Worte für gefunden. Er hat ja auch nochmal daran appelliert, an die Leute, sich gemeinschaftlicher zu denken. Nicht so sehr zu individualisieren, sondern auch nochmal unterstrichen, dass man eben als Gemeinschaft mehr bewegen kann. Und deswegen, glaube ich, kann und sollte beides existieren. Es sollten die euphorischen und die ausgelassenen Familienbilder existieren, aber es sollte irgendwie auch im Hinterkopf bleiben, was vor und nachher passiert ist und vor allem auch nachher. Wir haben jetzt noch ein paar Tage EM vor uns, aber danach auch noch ein paar Wochen, in denen sowas dann schnell mal in der Schublade versinkt. Aber ich glaube, da ist es total wichtig, wachsam zu bleiben, auch weiter drauf zu gucken, was nach diesem Familienfoto so passiert.
Und wie kann das gut passieren, Ruben? Also wir reden jetzt ja auch während der EM. Weiß nicht, ob ich in einem Jahr noch mal drüber sprechen werde, was sie seitdem getan hat, weil ja auch die plakativen Beispiele fehlen. Man fischt immer so ein bisschen im Trüben.
Ich würde sagen, es wird eine andere Art von Diskussion geben, einfach aufgrund dessen, dass viele, ich nenne es mal Fußballfans in diesem Kontext wahrscheinlich erst wieder in zwei Jahren auftauchen werden. Und von daher wird es eine andere Art von Diskussion sein. Nichtsdestotrotz, der Fußball hat eine exkludierende, aber auch eine extrem inkludierende Wirkung. Ich glaube, das muss man sich immer wieder vergegenwärtigen. Deswegen reden wir auch gerade hier über dieses Thema, weil wir Fußball ja trotzdem auch etwas, das hast du mit deiner Einleitung wunderbar dargestellt, weil Fußball etwas ist, was Menschen zusammenbringt. Wenn ich eben, wie gesagt, an alle möglichen Spiele, die ich in meinem Leben besucht habe, mit Freundinnen, Menschen, die ich beim Fußball kennengelernt habe, hat es natürlich diese inkludierende Wirkung. Die Frage ist, wie können wir diesen Sport zu einem Sport machen, bei dem alle willkommen sind? Und das klingt so ein bisschen nach UEFA-Marketingspot. Aber grundsätzlich ist es die Sache, der Fußball kann Leute zusammenbringen. Und ich glaube auch, dass die EM an vielen Stellen etwas dazu beigetragen hat. Wenn wir mal diesen im Kontext europäischer Einheit denken, bin ich davon überzeugt, dass diese EM auch dazu etwas beigetragen hat, trotz dieser Vorfälle, über die wir jetzt knapp eine Stunde lang geredet haben.
Ich habe vor dieser Sendung noch das Input und Feedback aus der Community zu diesem Thema geholt. Und das wäre gerne was, womit ich jetzt dann enden würde. Ich habe so ein paar Beiträge mal rausgesucht. Vielen Dank für die gute Diskussion da. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, war alles unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und ich glaube, das, was so ein bisschen anknüpft an dem, über das wir sprechen, das hat Ehrenmund formuliert. Er hat geschrieben, Zitat, An dieser Stelle muss man aber auch eine klare Unterscheidung treffen. Wolfsgruß, Defend Europe-Banner und Gesänge zur Melodie von Lamour Toujour ziehen immer gegen andere. Partynationalismus kann so sein, muss es aber nicht. Wir haben in meinen Augen bei dieser EM auch gesehen, dass sich in Nationalflacken gehölt Leute mit anderen Fahnen verbrüdert haben, sich sogar über nationale Klischees lustig gemacht haben, Baguettes oder Spaghetti wurden in Freundschaft zerbrochen. Auch ein Satz, bei dem ich nicht gedacht hätte, dass man die nach dieser EM so sagt. Jetzt geht es weiter mit dem Zitat. Und man konnte vor allem auch sehen, wie Menschen unterschiedlichster Herkunft ein Querschnitt einer offenen Gesellschaft sich unter den Farben der Bundesrepublik versammelt haben. Währenddessen haben zum Teil Menschen, welche sich nach dem alten Reichsbanner über dem Reichstag sehen, aus vielen Gründen die deutsche Nationalmannschaft boykottiert. Vielleicht, weil wer zusammenfeiert, auch zusammen wächst. Unsere Nationalfarben wurden also aktiv besetzt und dem alleinigen Geltungsanspruch von rechts außen entzogen und quasi zurück in unsere Mitte geholt. Zumindest in Teilen, es wäre ein schöner Gedanke.
Ja, ich hatte auch direkt ein Bild in meinem Kopf dazu von der Berliner Fanmeile. Letzte Woche waren es zwei Mädchen, beide so 13, 14. Die eine hatte eine Spanienflagge, die andere eine Deutschlandblumenkette um den Hals gebunden. Die spielen zusammen bei einem Berliner Fußballverein, Amateurverein, Fußball, die eine Spanierin, die andere Deutsche. So haben sie sich vorgestellt. Die waren da auch arm in arm und meinten, ich habe sie gefragt, ob es dann auch ein bisschen kriselt bei dem Ergebnis, da meinten sie direkt, nein, gar nicht, wir unterstützen uns gegenseitig, wir wollen einfach zusammen Fußball gucken. Das sind ja auch Bilder, das sind ja auch Erzählungen, die es auch gab bei der EM. Und es wurde da ja auch sehr ausgelassen, so Reggaeton getanzt von deutschen und spanischen Fans gemeinsam. Das sind so Bilder, die man da auf jeden Fall auch festhalten kann. Die glaube ich ganz gut in die Bilder von dem Hörer, den du gerade vorgelesen hast, mit reinpassen.
Ich glaube, dass vor allem die musik der holländischen Fans wahrscheinlich auch demnächst auf den einen oder anderen deutschen Festen gespielt werden wird. Ich glaube, das ist natürlich auch ein grün-noveller Austausch durch die Musik, der da stattfinden wird, wenn wir über schöne Bilder während dieser Europameisterschaft noch mal abschließend reden wollen. Dann glaube ich, sind die holländischen Fans da etwas... Also ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich habe am Anfang von dieser Feindschaft, der Fußballfeindschaft zwischen den Niederlanden und Deutschen gesprochen. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist inzwischen eher so, dass sehr, sehr viele deutsche Fans hoffen, dass die Niederlanden diese Europameisterschaft gewinnen. Das ist zumindest mein Eindruck so. Und dass vor allem auch die holländischen Fans sehr viel Sympathien in den letzten Wochen bei deutschen Fans gesammelt haben. Was ich auch glaube ich, seit ich Fußball verfolge, so in der Art und Weise noch nie wahrgenommen habe.
Ja, ist ein interessanter Aspekt. Gleichzeitig natürlich wieder eine Fan-Gruppierung, der wir uns aus verschiedenen Gründen auch äußerlich näher fühlen. Also mir fehlt immer noch so, dass man sich mal so schockverliebt in eine wirklich so andersartige Kultur, dass man sie deutlicher als fremd empfindet. Also ich kann mich zum Beispiel noch erinnern, bei der WM 2006 war Trinidad und Tobago so damals im Kleinen, so wie die betrunkenen Schotten heute im Großen. Dass man sich damals gefreut hat. Und dass aber auch viele Menschen überrascht waren. Mensch, wie viele eigentlich hier leben, die dieses Team unterstützen. Das gibt es ja gar nicht, weil die sich eben in den entsprechenden Austragungsorten dann alle versammelt haben. Und das hat man ja aber bei dieser EM auch sehen können. Also es war die EM, ich habe es vor dem Turnier noch gehofft, und ich glaube jetzt kann man es sagen, mit den meisten Heimspielen für Teams, weil eben natürlich von außen aus den Ländern natürlich sehr viele nach Deutschland gereist sind, weil Deutschland auch gut erreichbar ist und die Stadien auch groß genug sind, aber weil es eben auch sehr viele hier lebende Menschen gibt, Deutsche gibt, die andere Nationen unterstützen. Und das, muss ich sagen, ist für mich so etwas, was mir richtig wehgetan hat rund um die Wolfsgruß-Debatte, die richtig und wichtig war. Und ich möchte vor allem wissen, wie verhält sich da jetzt die Politik zu? Wird jetzt weiter ignoriert, dass es Menschen gibt, die in Deutschland leben, die von dieser Gruppe bedroht werden? Oder wird da etwas getan, auf welchen Ebenen auch immer? Das ist mir wichtig. Aber was mir daran so wehgetan hat, war, im Grunde hätte man die Türkei doch als eine Art Co-Gastgeber bezeichnen können. Einfach aufgrund der Migrationsgeschichte, die Deutschland hat. Das hat auch irgendjemand bei YouTube so beschrieben. Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Und man hätte eigentlich auch sagen können, Mensch, Deutschland ist jetzt ausgeschieden. Komm, jetzt holt euch den Titel. Wie geil wäre das denn? Und wir fahren alle mit im Autokorso. Aber weil da zu Recht auch viel Kritik geübt wurde, wurde einem das genommen. Und diese Debatte konnte auch gar nicht mehr geführt werden. Und ich habe es eher so empfunden, weiß nicht, Inga, wie es dir ging, dass viele Leute auch deshalb erleichtert waren, dass die Türkei verloren hat. Und irgendwie ist da auch eine Chance flöten gegangen. Ich hätte total gerne mich mitgefreut mit ganz vielen Menschen, die schon ewig lange in Deutschland leben, Deutsche sind, aber eben aufgrund ihrer Herkunft da ganz große Emotionen mit diesem Team verbinden. Mit denen hätte ich mich eigentlich gerne mitgefreut.
Ja, Co-Gastgeber finde ich auch eine kreative Idee. Und es war schon Wahnsinn zu beobachten, wie viele Fans der jeweiligen Mannschaften in den Stadien waren. Es waren ja ganze einfarbige Blöcke. Das war schon sehr eindrucksvoll zu sehen. Und es gab ja auch dieses friedliche Beieinander zusammen Feiern auf den Fan-Mayen. Gab es das ja in Teilen auch. Also ja, diese Bilder bleiben. Und an denen kann man das Bild auch ein bisschen festhalten.
Das ist eben der eine Aspekt dieses Turniers. Und dann hat Bluten Oli noch einen weiteren mitgebracht im Forum. Er schreibt, müssen wir es nicht einfach aushalten, wenn der türkische Nachbar im Gespräch beim Hecke schneiden mir erklärt, welche Bedeutung der Gruß der grauen Wölfe für ihn hat. Und erst dann, sofern die Deutung Richtung graue Wölfe geht, es kritisch anmerken und diskutieren. Also sprich, Ruben, hier wird mal thematisiert, ob wir nicht auch mehr miteinander reden sollten. Und vielleicht auch manchmal mit Leuten reden sollten, von denen wir erstmal annehmen, dass wir ihre Meinung ablehnen. Oder vielleicht auch ihre Meinung offen ablehnen. Wie denkst du darüber?
Ich glaube, damit macht man sich es zu einfach. Und ja, es gibt die Bezüge zur Mythologie natürlich. Gleichermaßen hat auch das Hakenkreuz eine andere Bedeutung gehabt, bevor es die Nationalsozialistinnen instrumentalisiert bzw. missbraucht haben. Und ich glaube, im Kontext der Grauen Wölfe kann man durchaus sagen, dass der Wolfsgruß eben nicht nur ein Verweis auf die Mythologie und auf die Geburtsstunde des Türkentums zurückzuführen ist, sondern eben auch durch die Ülkücü-Bewegung für eine nationalistisch-rassistische Ideologie steht, die in der Vergangenheit Gewalttaten zu morden, wie ich anfangs gesagt habe, auch hier in Deutschland, da ist. Und als jemand, der selber schon Morddrohungen von Grauen Wölfen erhalten hat, kann ich das in der Art und Weise nicht so sehen, ebenso wie viele andere türkisch-stämmige Menschen in Deutschland. Von daher weiß ich nicht, ob man das aushalten muss.
Ja, du hast quasi jetzt am Schluss das Punkt zu einem Blutenolli ausgesetzt. Ich glaube auch, wenn solche Haltung erkennbar werden, und ich meine, wir alle versammeln uns vor dem universellen Anspruch der Menschenrechte, an dem wir uns aber auch selber messen müssen, dann ist es ja klar, dass man das nicht aushalten muss, in Anführungszeichen, aber das miteinander reden und das nachfragen, fand ich einen interessanten Gedanke, weil ich hatte das Gefühl, dass es sehr schnell bei dieser EM so war, und jetzt vor allem jetzt im Fall der Türkei, dass wir über andere geredet haben und eben viel zu wenig gefragt haben, wie denkt ihr selbst darüber? Und dann, wenn man dann eine Antwort bekommt, die eben nicht auf dem Basis unserer Werte, also unserer jetzt in großen Anführungszeichen basiert, ja klar, dann, also man muss nicht alles akzeptieren. Das wollte ich damit nicht sagen. Ich denke, das wollte auch Olli in dem Fall nicht sagen. Aber ich glaube, das war der Aspekt. Inga, hast du da noch Gedanken dazu?
Naja, ich glaube, dahinter steht eine relativ große Debatte. Aber miteinander reden, diskutieren und die Debatten auch führen, ist glaube ich total wichtig. Und beim Thema Zuhören, Betroffenen zuhören, also Menschen, die von der Gewalt, die von den grauen Wölfen ausgeht, zuhören. Diese Stimmen auch in Runden, den Gehör verschaffen, zu Sichtbarkeit beitragen. Ich glaube, das sind ganz zentrale Punkte. Aber ja, ich bin immer auch dafür, da im Dialog zu bleiben. Aber natürlich bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt.
Und dazu hat, und das wäre jetzt dann der letzte Aspekt, den ich noch gerne kurz mit euch besprechen würde, Mac Crab auch was geschrieben im Forum. Er sagt nämlich, er oder sie, ich weiß es nicht, was immer wir sehen, der Wolfsgruß ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür, ist doch nur eine sehr oberflächliche, schlaglichtartige Reflektion einer viel tiefer gehenden Debatte oder eines viel tiefer in der Gesellschaft ablaufenden Prozesses. Nur dass die emotionale Eskalation bei so einem großen Turnier diese Vorgänge, die auch ohne EM genauso abläufen würden, völlig verzerrt. Mit anderen Worten, der überall sich wieder abzeichnende Stärkung, die sich überall wieder abzeichnende Stärkung einer nationalen Selbstwahrnehmung in breiten Bevölkerungsschichten ist ein super interessantes und wichtiges Thema. Aber was dann bei der EM passiert, ist nur sensationell und geht nicht im Geringsten an die Wurzeln dieser Entwicklung ran. Ich halte jedenfalls nichts von der These, dass Fußballturniere diesbezüglich eine Wirkungskraft entfalten können. Sie sind immer nur symptomatisch. Ruben, du hast schon sehr viel genickt. Ich habe das Gefühl, hier Zustimmung herauszusehen.
Das Stadion ist Brennglas der Gesellschaft. Die Sachen, die wir in der Gesellschaft erleben, zeigen sich auch noch mal versteckt im Stadion. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass der Fußball diese integrative Wirkung haben kann und auch dementsprechend gesellschaftspolitische Diskussionen anstoßen kann. Das sieht man allein schon, wie viele beispielsweise Bundesligavereine sich zu gesellschaftlichen Themen äußern. Vereine, die eigene Laufgruppen beim Christopher-Street-Day organisieren, sich am Gedenktag, am 27. Januar, am Gedenktag für die Opfer des Nationalsozialismus engagieren. Also ich glaube schon, dass der Fußball auch eine Wirkung hat, die weit über das Stadion hinausgehen kann. Deswegen stimme ich der Person bis zum Ende absolut zu, dass der Fußball sein kann, weil der Fußball ist zwar eine politische Plattform, meiner Meinung nach, aber er ist trotzdem auch nicht die Plattform, auf der wir tatsächlich fachgerecht auch über Politik sprechen sollten, weil dafür gibt es andere Kanäle, dafür gibt es Diskussionsrunden, dafür gibt es die Parlamente, dafür gibt es Parteien. Aber der Fußball trägt meiner Meinung nach definitiv einen Teil zu dieser Debatte bei.
Inga, deckt sich das mit deiner Meinung?
Und ich glaube, der Beitrag passt auch gut zu dem, was wir schon gesagt haben. Also, dass schon seit Jahren Personen versuchen, auf die Problematik der Grauen Wölfe, auf die Gefahr, die von ihnen ausgeht, aufmerksam zu machen und es einfach kaum gehört wird, dass es kaum Sensibilisierung für das Thema gibt. Und jetzt aber der Aufschrei sehr groß ist. Also, ich glaube, dass dieser Aspekt der Symptomatik da auch sehr zutreffend ist.
Ja, und es ist interessant, wenn man vor allem dann mal den größeren Bogen spannt. Also, ich habe da vor dieser Sendung drüber nachgedacht, weil ich eben viel über die Rolle der Medien nachgedacht habe, bei dieser Europameisterschaft, welche Rolle eigentlich der Rasenfunk und das, was ich hier getan habe in den letzten Jahren, einnimmt. Und man kann da eigentlich schon den größeren Bogen spannen. Zu EM 2016 kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass wir hier im Rasenfunk so wirklich die großen politischen und sociologischen Diskussionen geführt haben. Spätestens mit der WM 2018, wo ich aber schon ein halbes Jahr vorher angefangen habe, mit Katrin Scheib regelmäßig zu sprechen. Da haben wir viel gesprochen über Menschenrechte, über zivilgesellschaftlichen Aktivismus, wie der zur Zeit der WM in Teilen zurückgedrängt wurde, in Teilen aber auch zugelassen wurde und was dann aber auch danach nicht passiert ist. Und ich glaube, ausgehend von diesen Gesprächen kann man dann ganz gut einen Bogen spannen. Es wurde immer mehr. Die WM in Katta hat natürlich dazu eingeladen. Es hat dazu geführt, dass sie auch hier im Rasenfunk boykottiert wurde. Und jetzt ist das kein Höhepunkt, aber ich glaube, für mich steht das in einer Reihe, was wir jetzt gerade hier besprochen haben. Mein Eindruck ist, dass vielleicht die große Entwicklung unserer Zeit ist, dass sich gesellschaftliche Probleme so verschärfen, dass wir auch im Fußball immer schlechter drum herumkommen und dass wir aber auch aus anderen Gründen auch noch darüber sprechen wollen und auch den Fußball an seinen eigenen Worten messen wollen. Denn der Fußball behauptet immer unpolitisch zu sein, aber diese Diskussion, damit will ich gar nicht mehr einsteigen. Wer das noch behauptet im Jahr 2024, der braucht auch den Rest dieser Sendung nicht hören. Deswegen wollte ich diese Frage zum Eingang gar nicht stellen. Da sind wir uns alle einig und da versichern wir uns nur gegenseitig, wie richtig wir das sehen. Aber das ist eben, glaube ich, so die große Linie, die man vollführen kann. Und da wird diese EM aber auch dann wieder ein Beispiel sein. Also wir werden, ich weiß nicht in welcher Art, aber wir werden zur Weltmeisterschaft darüber sprechen. Wir werden ganz sicher im Bereich des Frauenfußballs noch oft über solche Themen sprechen, weil die da nämlich ganz anders thematisiert werden. Total interessanter Aspekt. Diese Turniere habe ich jetzt gerade ausgespart, weil wir da über solche Aspekte gar nicht sprechen mussten bisher. Vielleicht kommt das aber auch mehr. Also das ist doch interessant. Und da sehe ich dann auch quasi diese Sendung, die nur ein Ausschnitt sein kann einer Debatte, die man aber dann in einem größeren Kontext sehen muss und die ganz sicherlich in zukünftigen Sendungen, die in einem halben Jahr, in einem Jahr, vielleicht auch in zwei Jahren erscheinen, glaube ich dann ihren Widerhall finden. Deswegen danke ich euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch darauf eingelassen habt. Es war kein einfaches Thema, das zu besprechen. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Inga Hofmann. Folgt ihr sehr gerne auf Twitter, auf Mastodon. Ich werde alles verlinken. Danke, dass du mal im Rasenfunk warst. Das hat mich eigentlich mit am meisten gefreut.
Ja, ich habe mich auch sehr gefreut. Vielen, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Sehr, sehr gerne, jederzeit wieder. Und genauso geht das raus an Ruben Gerczikow. Ganz herzlichen Dank auch für deine Arbeit. Das möchte ich noch mal ausdrücklich sagen, weil eben du ganz wesentlich dafür mitverantwortlich bist, dass auch die in Anführungszeichen kleineren Vorfälle, also die, die leichter nicht in der Öffentlichkeit stattgefunden hätten, schon thematisiert wurden, bevor dann die in Anführungszeichen großen Vorfälle kamen, die auch zu Sanktionen geführt haben und deswegen logischerweise überall thematisiert wurden. Also vielen Dank für deine Arbeit, Publizist und Autor Ruben Gerczikow. Und ich danke dann auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Ich werde noch ein paar Links in die Show Notes packen zu dieser Sendung. Zum einen natürlich einen tollen Artikel von Harald, den habe ich glaube schon zweimal jetzt empfohlen bei dieser EM, wo er eben viele, viele Fälle auflistet, auch mit Ruben gesprochen hat in diesem Beitrag. Ich werde ein Deutschlandfunk-Sportgespräch verlinken, auch auf jeden Fall die Quelle des Zitats von Albrecht Sonntag. Und der Balabalabalkang-Podcast hat auch eine total interessante Folge gemacht, vor allem interessiert, also interessant fand ich vor allem an dieser Folge, die Emotionalität, mit der dort die vorliegenden Fälle diskutiert wurden und die These eines der Beteiligten, der gesagt hat, warum soll ich das überhaupt noch gucken, wenn die alle ihr nationalistisches Spiel draus machen aus dieser EM. Hat bei mir viele Gedanken angeregt, könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das auch bei euch passiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, also hört sehr gerne auch in diese Folge rein. Es wird alles verlinkt in den Show Notes und ich freue mich auch schon über die Diskussion hierzu. Ich musste mich manchmal ein bisschen verbiegen in meiner Rolle als Moderator. Ich hoffe, ihr legt mir das nicht so negativ aus, aber gut, ich werde es aushalten müssen. Und dann danke ich natürlich als letztes noch allen, die mit ihrer Unterstützung diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht haben. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Alles im Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Und auch deshalb können wir die Themen hier so setzen, in der Art und Weise, wie wir wollen. Hier redet niemand rein, außer Frank und ich, die die Entscheidung treffen, was wir hier machen. Das heißt, herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützt haben. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Nicolas, bei dem Unterstützer, den ich persönlich am liebsten habe, bei Jan Grobi, bei Prisemuth und bei Läuft bei mir, Daniel. Das heißt, ganz herzlichen Dank für eure Unterstützung. rasenfunk.de/supportersclubist die Adresse eurer Wahl. Und unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. Ihr könnt noch den allerletzten Merch des Rasenfunks kaufen. Und wir wissen nicht, ob oder wann es noch mal Merch geben wird. Ist gerade 50 Prozent reduziert. Wir lösen unser Lager auf. Helft uns dabei, dass dieses Lager dann auch wirklich nicht mehr existiert. Also zumindest nichts mehr vom Rasenfunk in diesem Lager existiert. kiosk.rasenfunk.de In diesem Sinne, hier im Rasenfunk geht's natürlich noch weiter mit der sportlichen Berichterstattung. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich wieder. Bis dahin bleibt gesund und macht's gut.
Das war der Rasenfunk, von Ihnen unterstützt. Herzlichen Dank.